Germany says China is operating two
illegal police stations on its territory
these setups don't have a fixed office
and are run by private individuals from
the Chinese diaspora the aim to collect
information on Chinese dissidents and
citizens in Exile and pass that on to
Beijing it's a pattern that's come to
light across the world an earlier report
by madrid-based NGO Safeguard Defenders
claimed if there were more than a
hundred such police stations in at least
53 countries most exist illegally and
aim to monitor coerce and in some
instances repatriate those Beijing
considers criminal or anti-china
a run-of-the-mill convenience store
an innocuous office unit in the suburbs
and a residential home like any other
just some of the unremarkable places
alleged to be woven into a vast secret
network of Chinese overseas police
stations
in a new report Spanish NGO Safeguard
Defenders reveal evidence of beijing's
clandestine operation they say it's used
to harass and intimidate the Chinese
diaspora
and the scale is breathtaking at least
100 such police stations in 53 countries
worldwide in Canada alone there are
thought to be four
we've known for many years that there
are consistent engagements by uh
representatives of the Chinese
government into Canadian communities
with local media
reports of uh illicit Chinese police
stations these are all things that we
continue to be concerned about that are
officials stay active on and that we
will continue to be vigilant around to
keep Canadians safe the issue came to
the fore at last month's G20 Summit in
Bali Justin Trudeau told journalists he
raised his concerns with Cheney's
president Xi Jinping
she scolded his counterpart over the
incident
everything
Beijing says the overseas police network
is to help citizens process paperwork or
to crack down on corruption
in 2019 Chinese law enforcement began
officially working in Cambodia
since then hundreds of Chinese citizens
accused of Telecom fraud have been
deported without due process
the FBI says that the latest Revelations
however mark an illegal expansion of
China's police state
because we have seen a clear pattern
of the Chinese government the Chinese
Communist Party exporting
their trans their repression right here
into the U.S and we've had now a number
of indictments that you may have seen of
the Chinese engaging in uncoordinated
law quote unquote law enforcement action
right here in the United States
harassing stalking surveilling
blackmailing uh people who they just
don't like or who disagree with the XI
regime
the US and a number of European
countries including Germany have now
opened investigations into the
allegations of Chinese foul play on
their soil
and for more context of this I'm joined
by Laura Hart she's a campaign director
at NGO Safeguard Defenders and joins me
from Rome Mrs hath welcome who is
running these illegal police stations I
mean are we talking of Chinese spies
diplomats police persons
thank you for having me uh from what we
gathered
um from the Chinese authorities
themselves and from Chinese media
reports on this subject which is uh the
exclusive basis of of our reporting on
this so we only used and I wish to
highlight this uh open source material
available online from Chinese
authorities local authorities and and
the media itself so what we see from
their statements is that these so-called
overseas Police Service Centers or
police linkage centers they have
different names depending on what local
jurisdiction is running them we're set
up by these local public security
bureaus we identified four of them in
close cooperation with the united front
work department so it appears that these
have been set up on top of let's say an
existing network of united front
organizations and people tied to those
organizations around the world so we
have no reason at this time to believe
that people were brought into countries
to exercise these functions that these
are you know traditional spies or or
public security agents
um we cannot exclude that but we have no
evidence at this point that that this
would be the case it really seems that
they are using existing networks United
front networks that have been there to
build this extra function on
you're talking about an extra function
but isn't there an element of legality
here as well for instance China does
have joint police patrolling
arrangements with countries like Italy
Serbia and Croatia surely police
stations are a part of that deal aren't
they
I don't think they're a part of the deal
or they they shouldn't be
um there's this varying responses to
that we see for example that when it
comes to the service stations and so we
need to also
um diversify a bit between the different
functions so one part of the functions
of these so-called service stations is
in helping in the renewal of passports
driver's licenses so more traditional
Consular tasks now while these are
worrying also um because if run by
united front uh networks and and
obviously we know that these are
instruments that have been used in in
transnational repression efforts from
the Chinese Communist party but in
general these kind of Consular Services
might be legal if and only if and when
the host government consented to the
setup of such let's call them Consular
outposts from what we gathered that
seems to be the case for example in
South Africa that does not seem to be
the case however in countries such as
Italy Croatia or others where there are
agreements on joint police patrols but
which is something completely different
and for example in Italy we've now
started to get some responses from the
interior Minister who clearly stated
that this was not part of the deals uh
so obviously we see from the Chinese
side from their statements that they
used these joint police patrols um to
set up these kind of stations that they
they claim that these stations are one
of the biggest achievements of those who
joined police patrols but they do not
seem to be part of what the government
consented to so there's a lot of
different things going on here but it
must be clear that in a majority of
countries where we found them because
there was no Express agreement by the
host governments even on the so-called
administrative Consular tasks these are
fully clandestine and I don't think any
government really even the South African
authorities have denied that they
consulted to the policing activities
that these stations these networks have
been involved in your organization
uncovered this network using publicly
available sources open source material
essentially presumably this is something
that the governments could have done as
well were governments lacking
look when it comes to
we came across these stations because we
are mapping and tracking the
transnational repression efforts from
the Chinese Communist party and in
particular the what we call involuntary
returns so both illegal and illegal
methods that the Chinese Communist party
and its state bodies use to bring people
back to China at all costs so as we were
tracking these we also came across the
setup of these stations as a part of of
these efforts of transnational
repression and transnational policing
could governments have come across this
they probably should have especially in
some cases for example in Ireland where
there was a clear sign outside the door
of the building actually saying you know
fujao overseas Police Service Center so
it's a bit worrying that that didn't
happen but I would say that goes to a
deeper underlying issue which is I think
in most countries still there's a lack
of awareness a lack of willingness a
lack of sense of urgency in
investigating and countering these
transnational repression efforts coming
from the Chinese Communist party but I
would say also the awareness and
willingness to affront confront counter
The Wider influence and interference
operations run by among others these
United front work department networks so
we hope that this kind of Investigation
will finally Open the Eyes of various
governments around the world that this
is something that really needs to be
countered and hopefully they will do so
in a coordinated way to learn from each
other and to set up a common framework
to counter these efforts
Laura hath we'll leave it there thank
you so much for joining us today